if you stopped playing fallout 76
because the world felt dead and empty I
don't blame you after a rocky start in
two pretty middling expansions there
hasn't really been a compelling reason
to return to West Virginia but
wastelanders is something different and
it just might make you want to play
again here's why right off the bat the
game's main quest see some big changes
with the new characters you'll encounter
a pair of titular wastelanders as soon
as you exit vault 76 so instead of just
moving from landmark to landmark and
reading logs from vault 76 is overseer
along the way other NPCs may offer
information about tracking her down
in fact the overseer herself is actually
a key part of wastelanders own story
quest and guess what you'll meet her in
person seeing her face to face even
makes the original game's main quest
more meaningful as you can finally speak
to her in the present not just listen to
her audio logs from the past in fact the
game overall finally feels alive in
wastelanders thanks to a more lived-in
world the first quest you'll likely pick
up starts at a bar called the wayward
owned by Duchess and frequented by some
of her cronies no spoilers here but
there are some fun twists along the way
as you help her hunt down a hidden
treasure as you work to pinpoint the
stash
you'll be sent over hills and into
mining tunnels where you'll encounter
other characters in the middle of their
own adventures knowing that others are
out there doing things when you're not
around
makes the world feel so much more alive
it's not just quest NPCs you'll stumble
upon either I found a fresh dead body
outside of a tent surrounded by wolves
seeing a skeleton would have told me
that something happened here long ago
whereas seeing a recently deceased NPC
meant the danger was still nearby this
environmental storytelling is
strengthened knowing things are actually
happening without your vault dwellers
involvement going back to the wayward
what's interesting about this location
is that it's an instance another key
addition and wastelanders you can think
of them almost like safe houses when
you're inside the interior is unique to
you only you and your teammates can
enter and only the team leader will gain
progress from the active quest certain
characters may come in and out of the
building
and objects in the environment may
change as checkpoints are reached this
also means you won't enter an instance
and find it totally stripped of
resources and ammo because some other
schmuck got there before you the way
word is also where I encountered another
major change dialogue trees it's nice to
actually talk to somebody and fallout 76
you know probably worth looking into if
you think you could use a little
refresher like previous Fallout games
your special stats come into play during
dialogue with characters dialogue skill
checks were sorely missed and fallout 76
but now you can actually use your
strength score to intimidate someone
persuade them with your high charisma or
squeeze them for some extra caps after
running an errand
this is much more engaging than having a
robot order you around or listening to
hollow tapes of dead Brotherhood of
Steel soldiers you'll never meet you'll
spend a lot of time talking with the new
factions two rival groups have formed
cities and wastelanders the settlers and
foundation and the Raiders in the crater
these new hub locations are filled with
people you can actually talk to people
like traders and bartenders and quest
givers you will also encounter smaller
groups like the aggressive blood Eagles
and the crazed cult of the Mothman out
in the wild but there's no parlaying
with those people they're your enemies
no matter what but when it comes to
Raiders and settlers the new reputation
system gives you a reason to make
friends and help each encampment until
you complete an initial quest for each
group and get on their good side you'll
be untrusted and unable to actually do
business in town like buying supplies
reputation can be increased by
completing faction quests as well as
various daily and repeatable side
missions the Raiders for instance always
have some former members to track down
and deal with these activities ensure
you'll be able to make peace with the
Raiders and settlers which is key since
at some point the main quest will force
you to side with one or the other
offering that type of choice wasn't
possible before NPCs were added to the
game getting in good with the factions
can also win you allies and I don't just
mean you'll make friends with them
wastelanders has key characters that can
actually stay at your personal camp
these characters provide quests and yes
they are romance able to all together
these additions make the wasteland of
Fallout 76
feel much more alive I didn't care for
the original release much and despite
the games MMO like nature
I felt quite alone while playing it but
wastelanders gives me a reason to
explore again and friendly faces to meet
along the way so if the game felt dead
to you too you should jump back in to
see how vibrant it is now thanks to NPCs